[Music]
our cancellation brings us in a circle
much like the logic of my opponents on
dr phil
one of those opponents addison rose
vincent who's the one with the beard
posted a story to instagram shortly
before the episode aired yesterday
addison is not pleased
the post explains quote about a month
ago ethan and i were invited to be
guests on the dr phil show to share our
stories and discuss pronouns we were
excited for the opportunity to educate
in a safe space
so you see here by the way that they
were not looking for a debate they were
there to educate
and that means that they speak and the
rest of us shut up and listen
that's not exactly how it worked out for
them and now they're traumatized
back to the post
what ended up happening was much
different than we discussed than they
discussed with us and we left feeling
attacked by another guest and played by
the producers
well the other guest sounds like a jerk
i mean i can't believe he would do that
addison continues the episode airs today
and we're very worried about how the
whole thing will be edited if you want
to watch go for it but it may be
uncomfortable or triggering to do so
since the taping ethan and i have been
experiencing a heightened level of
anxiety to the point that we've had
numerous nightmares and depression
spirals over the last month this week
has been the worst
please send us both good vibes today we
could really use it we tried our best
with no preparation for what the dr phil
show actually had planned behind our
backs and we hope our visibility
inspires viewers viewers
well addison
it inspired me
and i hope you can take some solace in
that well one thing i can tell you as a
four-star chef myself
amateur chef but i consider myself a
four-star chef your kitchen is not
complete without
great kitchen knives and that's why you
need cami kota kamikoda taps into more
than 800 years of traditional techniques
from honshu japan kamikoto also uses
steel sourced from mills in japan and
each blade is crafted using techniques
that have been honed and perfected by
generations of knife smiths each knife
comes in a beautiful heavy-duty ash wood
box and makes sure that the knife is
stored safely as well each chemical
knife goes through a rigorous 19-step
process that takes several years from
start to finish to complete our expert
blade smiths forge and shape raw steel
into hearty blades
polishing and sharpening them to an
excruciatingly fine edge each knife is
individually inspected kamikoto is so
confident that their knives will work
for you that each knife comes with a
lifetime guarantee because of their
single bevel edge candy cota knives can
achieve an unbelievably sharp edge you
just can't get with other knives they
can cut through your rib eye like butter
that is guaranteed
kamikoto is currently having a massive
extended new year sale and on top of
that sale you can get an additional
fifty fifty dollars off any purchase you
make with discount code matt walsh so
click the link below or go to
kamikoda.com matt walsh and use promo
code matt walsh to save an extra fifty
dollars today now for the record they
these people were not tricked or fooled
by the producers we all had exactly the
same amount of information going in we
knew it would be a panel with people on
both sides of the issue that's all i
knew
that's all anybody knew
and as for the editing the editors did
the trans propaganda side a number of
favors
now i'm not going to claim that that it
was motivated by bias dr phil's team was
really fair to everybody i thought
but um things get cut for time
inevitably and so we all had big chunks
taken out i know that i did
and the more that they cut from the
addison side of it and that team the
better for them
because they only sounded more and more
deranged as the episode went on
so as bad as they sounded i can tell you
right now
it was much worse
in in real time
so what are addison and ethan the poor
deers really upset about
they knew they'd be facing off with
people who disagree with them
they also talk about these issues every
single day for a living
it's their job to go around promoting
this stuff
so wha
why did i traumatize them how
why am i now haunting their dreams
i mean this is me we're talking about
i'm a cuddly
nice and lovable guy
the answer is that our culture has so
effectively scared the same people into
silence that these propagandists have
been running essentially unopposed this
whole time
they've never run into any pushback
they've never encountered any friction
nobody has ever called them out on their
nonsense ever
for a lot of them
they've been so ensconced in their
bubble so comfortable in their
protective cocoon that it never even
occurred to them that anybody that
anybody would come on national
television and actually challenge their
position
the possibility was literally
unthinkable
they knew there'd be some kind of token
opposition some patsies brought up there
to represent some sanitized
approximation of the other side but they
expected that conversation to be rigged
in their favor
because it always is everywhere all the
time
now they still got a little bit of that
later in the episode two parents were
invited on to talk about their efforts
to keep this pronoun crap out of the
children's out of their children's
schools
and both of these parents are doing
important work and they're brave for
taking a stand and i commend them
but one of them began
i think with a mistake
by laying an offering at the feet of the
trans agenda watch this
first of all thank you for having me and
i wanted to say it's so i honor you and
your journey and where you are in life
and i it has nothing to do with that
it's we're here about our kids
and um so in school
i feel like this is a family issue it's
a parent child issue and it's a real
issue with some kids i think that the
percentage is quite small
for how many kids go through this real
serious issue
um and including and imposing this on
the entire school or the entire class is
where i have a problem
okay so that's exactly what addison and
ethan expected
that's what they want and demand and
require
they'll tolerate mild disagreement
if only for appearances sake
but you better be giving those
criticisms on your knees and apologizing
in advance for everything you say
i honor you she said
well addison and ethan i do not honor
you
i think you're completely wrong about
everything you say
what's more i think you're narcissists
and bullies
i think you don't give a damn about
anybody or anything but yourselves
i think you advocate for opening up
bathrooms and sports teams because from
your perspective the rape trauma and
abuse that happens as a result is worth
it
as long as your ideology wins the day
and your self-perceptions are reinforced
because that's all you care about
i think you represent something that is
not only anti-scientific and irrational
but evil
and i think you have evil intentions
i think you're bad people
and i think that you are neither correct
nor well-meaning
and if one person in the whole world in
your whole life
saying this to you causes you to spiral
into depression and be plagued by
nightmares
maybe that should clue you in
it sounds like your conscience is trying
to tell you something
you see people scream at me every day
and they say the most horrible things
about myself and my family i encounter
more outright hostility in a day
than you have in your whole life i
guarantee you that
i don't i didn't have the audience
clapping for me
you do
and yet i've slept like a baby every
night since that taping that's because i
know i'm standing in the truth not just
factually but morally
you don't have the same self-assurance
well
then maybe you should look within
yourself that's all you ever do anyway
you're constantly staring back into
yourself shouting into the cavern of
your own ego listening to the echo
well while you're in there
maybe try a bit of actual introspection
it might serve you well
in the meantime and i'm sorry if this
gives you even more nightmares
but sadly you are canceled
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
the matt well show if you did go ahead
and hit that subscribe button right down
there so you can stay up to date on all
of our future content